[Music]
starshine
bright
above you
children are running night breezes seem
to whisper i love you
birds singing in the sycamore tree
dream a little dream of me
[Music]
did you maybe clarify what sort of clues
we're supposed to be looking for here
the world is full of obvious things
which nobody by any chance ever observes
sherlock holmes
eleven if you're listening
[Music]
holy mother of
[Applause]
[Music]
something is coming
it is almost here
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new stranger things season 4
trailer they're having this big netflix
to them comic-con event it's sort of
their replacement for comic-con so
that's why we're getting all this
footage and all these new trailers so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
obviously this is all dropping next year
they haven't given us the exact release
date they're probably gonna wait till
early next year to drop another really
big trailer to tell you exactly which
day it's going to be dropping but just
starting at the beginning of the footage
and working our way through shot by shot
there's a couple other clips that i
haven't covered before that i'll also
include in this too because we've gotten
a couple teaser trailers for season four
so far but the first teaser trailer
starts with what they're calling the
creel house teaser like in the preview
where they were introducing the clip
they were saying we're on our former set
where we used to film the creel house
stuff but now it's just this living room
so creole house super important location
you're gonna get a taste of it right now
and i'm warning you it is very very
strange we hope you enjoy and uh we'll
see you soon you will enjoy it we're in
this one
but it actually starts with a huge
flashback to what seems like the 1950s
like this old-timey flashback clip of a
murder house called the creole house and
this is probably the creole family for
what it's named they play it like a
typical family moves in all happily to
this new house but in typical horror
genre fashion it winds up being a murder
house that's seemingly haunted but
because we're in the stranger things
universe a lot of what's happening in
the house when it seems like it's
haunted seems familiar to things that
were happening in the earlier seasons of
the show like as the old timey music
continues to play they start noticing
weird things around the house and it
kind of jump cuts forward in time like
the little girl sees the dead animal in
the yard they're sitting at dinner and
the electrical system starts going
haywire and starts flashing the radio
cuts in and out then when we jump
forward it just seems like the guy winds
up going crazy and killing the rest of
his family then it cuts to present day
with a version of the team basically
being ghostbusters they even have the
pin ghostbusters if you remember at the
beginning of season 2 they literally
dressed up as the ghostbusters for
halloween that year in getting super
meta with this one of the kids from
stranger things is in the ghostbusters
afterlife movie they're kind of doing
the stranger things where it's a
ghostbusters team of little kids it's
vin wolfhard who plays mike on stranger
things obviously playing a different
character in the ghostbusters universe
is this really weird meta thing going on
where they're parodying the ghostbusters
referencing ghostbusters stuff but we
actually have a ghostbusters movie with
a bunch of little kids in it the circle
of easter eggs are now complete but the
thing you might have noticed here when
the lights are flashing and things are
going crazy in the house the electrical
systems are going all haywire this
actually seems very similar to what was
happening in joyce and will's house when
will was in the upside down trying to
contact his mother flipping all the
lights trying to communicate with her to
let her know that he was alive just
trapped in another dimension
so because this is a stranger things
universe and we know that everything has
its own version of itself in the upside
down there's a version of this house in
the upside down the team seems like it's
investigating a way to get into the
upside down inside this murder house
like it's somewhere where the barrier
between the normal world and the upside
down is a little bit weaker like say
underneath the star court mall and at
the old hawkins lab that they closed the
portal to at the end of last year when
the big machine exploded you may also
remember way back a couple years ago in
one of the early early stranger things
season four teaser trailers there was a
clock sound and people were like is this
big ben it sounds like the big ben clock
now because we see the grandfather clock
chiming in this teaser trailer in the
creel house we know that that was what
it was referencing it's this grandfather
clock
[Music]
there were just all these questions
about how they were going to connect
with the hopper story line in russia we
did actually get some new hopper trailer
footage in the last big teaser trailer
with him and this flamethrower seemingly
still inside that russian prison like it
kind of seems like he's still in russia
the other really interesting thing about
the set design here even though it's
obviously meant to look really creepy
like a murder house typically would in a
horror movie the design on that stained
glass window on the front door with the
flower opening up kind of reminds you of
the head of the demogorgon opening up
like a really dangerous kind of flower
there was also a short teaser that they
released the other day too with them
investigating a bunch of news clippings
playing it as if dustin and the group
are investigating the murder house
before they go visit it
[Music]
as you can see it's just hyping up the
mystery of what's actually going on with
this house but like i said a lot of
these things that are happening here
seem familiar to what was happening at
will and joyce's house during season one
when he was in the upside down trying to
flip all the switches and communicate
with her messing with the electronics
but the other really really noticeable
thing here at the beginning of this clip
when all the kids walk in is they are
way older obviously in previous seasons
they had the two different story lines
where you have the high schoolers then
you have the young kids now as they get
older there's all the jokes about how
steve has kind of adopted most of the
kids he's like super best friends with
dustin now and a lot of the other kids
just seem like they are high schoolers
at this point even though they've all
gotten the same amount older lucas just
seems like he is way older than all the
other kids even though they're supposed
to be about the same age but you have
dustin's steve max robin who obviously
is there with steve because they're now
working together they're kind of like a
little sub team by themselves nancy and
lucas so we don't know where eleven is
in this clip we saw some other footage
of her with what seems like some
government stooges trying to hold her
back there's another clip of them at a
high school rally like school has begun
again at some point during the series as
they all come back to town i've already
mentioned the new footage of hopper with
the flamethrower and then we have the
new footage of this person walking away
from the car wreck that's burning in the
middle of the street so it's just a
mishmash of a bunch of new scenes and
obviously focusing on this krill house
is a really important location and what
seems like the early part of the season
in the way they're hyping up this
grandfather clock they're just trying to
make it seem like it has some deep
connection to the upside down like i
said it just sounds like this is going
to be a place where there'll be a
weakness in the barrier between
dimensions and the upside down weaker
than you would find some other place
because at some point they have to get
to the upside down to fight the actual
mind flare and defeat it in its home
dimension i think that's the whole idea
is that like they could defeat it as
many times as they want inside the
normal world as it slowly has broken in
over the couple seasons but like at the
end of last year that giant flesh goo
monster was really just as avatar so
they may have defeated it but they
didn't kill the actual mind flare itself
it was just sort of like a flesh puppet
being controlled by the mind flare from
the upside down the only thing we
haven't really gotten in the last couple
of big trailers is how they actually
reconnect with hopper and you tell all
the jokes about david harbour in the
black widow movie like oh he obviously
went over to russia became red guardian
and that's where hopper's been this
whole time but the way that david harbor
talks about the hopper character he says
that this is just like the down and
dirtiest that you've ever seen hopper
like it's actually a really really solid
season for hopper if you felt like the
characters had some ups and downs in the
previous seasons even though he's been a
main character the whole time like the
closest you'll get to seeing full-blown
action hero hopper obviously he's got to
escape from that russian prison so if
you remember that early stranger things
season 4 trailer with hopper on chain
gang in siberia russia you have this
character played by jaqen h'gar from
game of thrones most people know him as
jaqen h'ghar you may have seen him in
some other series recently he's a fairly
prominent actor but he's in at least a
couple episodes during season four at
the beginning of the season he's only
listed on imdb for episodes one and two
but his name is dimitri and the way his
character description reads is that he's
someone who befriends hopper so it
sounds like he winds up helping hopper
escape also relevant is the title of
episode 1 that revealed the title of
season 4 episode 1 is the hellfire club
so i'm assuming that this little
ghostbusters group that they put
together this murder mystery group
trying to investigate things like the
scooby gang they just wind up calling
the hellfire club like this is a special
new club that they've formed there's a
whole bunch more trailers that are going
to be coming at this big netflix event i
believe there's going to be a new
witcher season 2 trailer later tonight
so i'll try to do a video for that as
soon as possible as well make sure you
enable alerts so you don't miss any of
those videos and of course i'll do more
stranger things videos when they drop
more trailer footage for that but if you
spotted any easter eggs in this footage
that i didn't talk about in the video
just write it below in the comments
everyone click here to learn what's
going on with the new spider-man no way
home marvel lawsuit and click here for
my brand new eternals trailer for kit
harington's black knight character thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you